en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y los acompaño desde casa a
causa de la pandemia de coke 19
iniciamos este espacio con un estudio
que se realiza en londres y que usa una
herramienta con inteligencia artificial
que busca identificar síntomas de
deterioro cognitivo leve esto podría
ayudar a detectar el alzheimer de forma
temprana la empresa responsable se llama
cognitiva y esto es lo que explican de
la herramienta por email lo que
realmente estamos midiendo la velocidad
de procesamiento de la información es
realmente el poder de procesamiento en
el cerebro y lo hacemos mostrándole a la
persona secuencias de imágenes de corta
duración
básicamente aparecen y preguntamos si
puedes o no ver un animal en las
imágenes esto realmente es importante
porque la detección de un estímulo
animal es una parte importante de la
respuesta del cerebro humano es una
característica innata una habilidad que
tenemos y es importante porque
compromete una parte entera del cerebro
en esta tarea
los desarrolladores indican que al
tratarse de imágenes y de identificar si
se ve o no un animal
en las barreras idiomáticas que
presentan otras pruebas hospitalarias 18
instituciones médicas de londres entre
ellas el king's college están
adelantando análisis con este programa y
varios expertos aseguran que la prueba
examina funciones cerebrales específicas
no es una prueba de diagnóstico de una
enfermedad pero es una prueba de cómo se
desempeña el cerebro dicho esto es un
primer paso extremadamente importante en
el proceso de hacer un diagnóstico de la
enfermedad de alzheimer
la imagen entra en la retina pasa a
través de circuitos cerebrales a áreas
del cerebro que luego interpretan que
esta imagen es o no animal y luego
provoca una respuesta entonces cuando lo
ves así uno se da cuenta de que en
realidad hay muchos procesos
involucrados en esto y muchas cosas que
pueden salir mal porque estas
estructuras estas vías pueden verse
afectadas por todo tipo de enfermedades
all kinds of this is us esta herramienta
ya cuenta con la aprobación de uso de la
unión europea sin embargo los
desarrolladores continúan recolectando
para nutrir la inteligencia artificial y
que los diagnósticos sean cada vez más
precisos por henderson es un paciente de
72 años al que hace dos años le
detectaron alzhéimer en etapa temprana
él es uno de los participantes del
estudio con esta herramienta
estoy en un punto en el que reto más la
confianza que empezaría a llegar en
términos de hablar adecuadamente a la
gente e involucrarte en conversaciones
de nuevo volver al escenario atrás
habilite camino de regreso
amén
estoy mucho mejor que cuando empezó este
horrible proceso
cambiamos de tema y ahora vamos a israel
donde fueron desarrolladas unas gafas de
sol que cambian automáticamente de
aumento se llaman vision north y se
configuran vía bluetooth con una
aplicación móvil
estas son juniors son las primeras gafas
de sol con foco adaptable lentes de sol
que se adaptan para leer pero también
tienen modos de escenario básicamente
las puedes usar como yo lo hago ahora y
simplemente deslizando el dedo
puedes cambiar el enfoque de las gafas
de una distancia lejana a la de lectura
los lentes están hechos de un compuesto
llamado cristal líquido pixelado que se
adapta a las distintas distancias de
enfoque de una manera similar a como lo
hacen los ojos los desarrolladores
aseguran que sus lentes se dividen en
millones de píxeles diminutos capaces de
rotar las moléculas del cristal líquido
que hay en su interior es así cómo
cambian los ángulos de las moléculas y
se logra un número ilimitado de
distancias focales y una gran nitidez
en sundance encapsula mos la capa de
cristal líquido dentro del lente y esta
se conecta a la batería y el circuito de
control también agregamos una aplicación
compatible con los sistemas android y
ios y con la plataforma se ajustan
automáticamente las gafas a la
prescripción del usuario
de acuerdo con los fabricantes las gafas
usan poca energía por lo que una carga
les permite funcionar un día entero por
el momento su costo es de 229 dólares y
finalizamos con una aplicación
colombiana llamada tools especializada
en productos y materiales de
construcción y ferretería que cuenta con
un amplio catálogo de marcas y permite
realizar pedidos durante las 24 horas
del día y los 7 días de la semana el
ferretero de barrio puede comprar todo
lo que necesita en su negocio por medio
una aplicación a un clic de distancia y
en cinco minutos por medio nuestra
aplicación puede tener acceso a más de
5000 productos de 100 marcas
y en los tres países donde operamos
actualmente que son méxico colombia y
ecuador
el ferretero compra todo lo que necesita
sin órdenes mínimas sin pagar flete y
entregándole en 24 horas o menos en año
y medio de operación es la plataforma ha
atendido a más de 6000 clientes y busca
llegar a 20 mil ferreterías para el
final de 2021
así mismo expandir su cobertura a países
como brasil e incluso llegar a los
mercados africanos así finalizamos este
espacio a ustedes gracias por
acompañarme y recuerden que pueden
repetir este y otros programas en
nuestra web france24 puntocom
[Música]